foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's keynote president
presentation unraveling the role of the
ap4 adapter complex in protein sorting
and neurological disease this webinar is
part of the cell biology virtual event
and I'm Susie Valdez of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots so let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
you that this event is interactive and
we encourage you to participate
by first communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during this presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click submit we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation now if
you're having any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on the help desk button
located at the bottom of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby
and finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on that continuing education credits
link located at the abstract window
below the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain those credits I
now present today's speaker Dr Juan
bonifacino associate scientific director
of neurosciences and cellular structural
biology in the division division at
Eunice Kennedy Shriver National
Institute of child health and human
development and the National Institute
of Health Dr bonifacino was elected for
delivering the keynote address of the
American Society for cell biology today
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dr bonaficino
welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
thank you very much Susie for the
introduction and I'm very pleased to be
here this morning and good morning
everyone
uh or good afternoon wherever you are
today
uh so as Susie said I'm an investigator
at the Eunice Kennedy shribe
for National Institute of child health
and human development
and my lab does mainly basic research
on molecular mechanisms of protein
trafficking how proteins get to
different compartments within the cell
but we also apply knowledge gained from
those basic studies to the understanding
of molecular mechanisms of
disease in particular neurodevelopmental
disorders and today I would like to
present an example of that translation
from basic research to disease related
research
as Susie mentioned I will be talking
about the ap4 adapter complex it's a
component of the Machinery that ensures
that certain proteins are properly
delivered to their respective
compartments within the cell
and how uh the
effects in this complex cause a
particular disease known as
territory paraplegia
so the eukaryotic cell
um comprises a number of
membrane-bound compartment
s some of which you will be able to
appreciate in this electron micrograph
of a pituitary cell in particular this
is a cell that makes growth hormone and
therefore has a growth hormone
containing granules which you will be
able
to appreciate in the interior of this
cell
and you will also be able to see a
number of other
membrane Bond compartments including the
nucleus in the center of the cell the
plasma membrane that surrounds the the
cell and other organelles such as the
endoplasmic reticulum the Golgi complex
endosons
lysosomes and others
each of these intracellular compartments
has its
different protein composition which is
responsible for
the specific functions of those
organelles
and what we and other people in this
field are interested in understanding is
how is that heterogeneous distribution
of proteins within the cell achieved
in other words how do some proteins go
to the nucleus whereas others go to the
plasma membrane or to endosomes or
lysosomes what molecular mechanisms
ensure that these proteins go to the
correct compartments within the cell so
that's the problem that we are
interested in
and in particular we are interested
in organelles that make up the so-called
endomembrane system of the cell
which comprises the endoplasmic
reticulum on the left
the Golgi complex in the center
various types
of
endosomes and lysosomes and different
domains of the plasma membrane
um there is there are many different
machineries that ensure that proteins
are able to navigate this endomembrane
system and be delivered to their
respective compartments within the cell
among those components of the machinery
are four so-called adapter protein
complex or AP complexes
AP1 ap2 ap3 ap4 and ap5 which are shown
on this scheme at
the locations where we think they act
and what these complexes do is they
select
specific proteins that we call car
gos
for incorporation into transport
vesicles and then will move from one
compartment to the other
uh these adapter protein
complexes are composed of four subunits
which are shown here in schematic
fashion in different colors
uh they bind to
membranes
through interactions with specific
membrane phospholipids
and a specific
gtpaces so these are membrane bound
complexes
and then they function to recognize
sorting signals
in the cytosolic tales of transmembrane
proteins
leading to the concentration
of those transmembrane proteins within
areas of the membrane that contain this
adapter protein complexes in other
words
what these AP complexes do is grab
transmembrane proteins by the tail and
concentrate them in regions of the
membrane that would give rise to a
transport vesicle
then the adapters recruit scaffolding
proteins such as clathrin which is the
best known of these scaffolding protein
leading to the formation of a protein
coat on the membranes
that by electron microscopy can be seen
as an electron dense deposit on the
plasma membrane as shown here in this
electron micrograph of a so-called
clathrin coded head and the plasma
membrane
so these cluttering coded areas of the
membrane concentrate cargo proteins
via interactions with the adapter
protein complexes and away from other
proteins that don't have those certain
signals and that remain at the plasma
membrane
these clathrine coated pits then
imaginate
give rise to a coded vesicle which then
delivers those Cargoes those proteins to
another compartment within the cell in
the particular case of plasma membrane
proteins they are internalized into
so-called endosomes
similar processes take place not only at
the plasma membrane mediated by the ap2
complex but also the transology network
and various endosomal compartments uh
through
the function of complexes such as AP1
ap2 ap3 ap4 and ap5 in essence what all
of these complexes do is they recognize
a specific transmembrane proteins via
recognition of sorting signals in the
tales of these proteins that leads to
the capture
of those cargos within coded vesicles
that then deliver the vesicles from one
compartment to another
now these five complexes AP1 through
five have
similar but also different proteins they
are recruited to different membranes
via interactions with different uh
membrane phospholipids or different
gtpases and I'm not going to get into
that detail
but for this talk it's important to note
that mutations in subunits of each of
these five complexes
have now been reported to cause
different
genetic diseases different genetic
disorders which are shown here
and I'm
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation unraveling the role
of the ap4 adapter complex in protein
sorting and neurological disease this
webinar is part of the cell biology
virtual event and I'm Susie Valdez of
Labyrinth and I will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab Roots so
let's get started before we begin I want
to remind you that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by first communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during this presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click submit we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation now if
you're having any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credit click on that
continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits I now
present today's speaker Dr Juan
bonifacino associate scientific director
of neurosciences and so regular
structural biology in the division
division at Eunice Kennedy Shriver
National Institute of child health and
human development and the National
Institute of Health Dr bonifacino was
elected for delivering the keynote
address of the American society
for cell biology today for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen Dr bonifacino welcome you may now
begin your presentation sir
thank you very much
see for uh the introduction and I'm very
pleased to be here uh this morning and
good morning everyone
or good afternoon Wherever You Are
today
uh so as Susie said I'm an investigator
at the Eunice Kennedy Schreiber National
Institute of child health and human
development
and my lab does mainly basic research on
molecular mechanisms of protein
trafficking how proteins get to
different compartments within the cell
but we also apply knowledge gained from
those basic studies to the understanding
of molecular mechanisms of disease
in particular neurodevelopmental
disorders and today I would like to
present an example of that translation
from basic research to disease related
research as Susie mentioned I will be
talking about the ap4 adapter complex
it's a component of the Machinery that
ensures that certain proteins are
properly delivered
to their respective compartments within
the cell
and how the effects in this complex
cause
a particular disease known as hereditary
paraplegia
so the eukaryotic cell
comprises a number of
membrane-bound compartments some of
which you will be able to appreciate in
this electron micrograph of a pituitary
cell in particular this is a cell that
makes growth hormone and therefore has a
growth hormone containing granules which
you will be able to appreciate in the
interior of the cell
and you will also be able to see a
number of other
other membrane Bond compartments
including the nucleus in the center of
the cell
the plasma membrane that surrounds the
and other organelles such as the
endoplasmic reticulum the Golgi complex
endosons lysosomes and others
each of these intracellular compartments
has it responsible for the specific
functions of those organelles
and what we and other people in this
field are interested in understanding is
how is that heterogeneous distribution
of proteins within the cell achieved
in other words
how do some protons go to the nucleus
whereas others go to the plasma membrane
or to endosomes or lysosomes what
molecular mechanisms ensure that these
proteins go to the correct compartments
within the cell so that's the problem
that we are interested in
and in particular we are interested in
organelles that may
make up the so-called endomembrane
system of the cell
which comprises the endoplasmic
reticulum on the left the Golgi complex
in the center various types
of
endosomes and lysosomes and different
domains of the plasma membrane
um there is there are many different
machineries
that ensure that proteins are able to
navigate this endomembrane system and be
delivered to their respective
compartments within the cell
among those components of the Machinery
are four so-called adapter protein
complexes or AP complexes
AP1 ap2 ap3 ap4 and ap5 which are shown
on this scheme at the locations where we
think they act
and what these complexes do is they
select
specific proteins that we call cargos
for incorporation into transport
vesicles that then will move from one
compartment to the other
uh these adapter protein complexes are
composed of four subunits which are
shown here in schematic fashion in
different colors
uh they bind to
membranes
through interactions with specific
membrane phospholipids
and a specific
gtpses so these are membrane bound
complexes
and then they function to recognize
sorting signals
in the cytosolic tales of transmembrane
proteins
leading to the concentration of those
transmembrane proteins within areas of
the membrane that contain this adapter
protein complexes in other words
what these AP complexes do is grab
transmembrane proteins by the tail and
concentrate them in regions of the
membrane that would give rise to a
transport vesicle
then the adapters recruit scaffolding
proteins
such as clathrin which is the best known
of these scaffolding protein leading to
the formation of a protein coat on the
membranes
that by electron microscopy can be seen
as an electron dense deposit on the
plasma membrane as shown here in this
electron micrograph of a so-called
clathrin coded head at the plasma
membrane
so these cluttering coded areas of the
membrane concentrate cargo proteins
via interactions with the adapter
protein complexes and away from other
proteins that don't have those certain
signals and that remain at the plasma
membrane
uh these uh clathrine coated pits then
imaginate
give rise to a coded vesicle which then
differs those Cargoes those proteins to
another compartment within the cell in
the particular case of plasma membrane
proteins they are internalized
into so-called endosomes
similar processes take place not only at
the plasma membrane mediated by the ap2
complex but also the
transcology Network and various
endosomal compartments through the
function of complexes such as AP1 ap2
ap3 before and ap5 in essence what all
of these
complexes do is they recognize uh
specific transmembrane proteins via
recognition of sortings
signals in the Tails of these proteins
that leads to the capture
of those cargos Within
body vesicles that then deliver the
vesicles from one compartment to another
now the
these five complexes AP one through five
uh have
similar but also different
proteins they are recruited to different
membranes uh via interactions with
different uh
membrane phospholipids or different
gtpases and I'm not going to get into
that detail
but for this talk it's important to note
that mutations in subunits of each of
the
SE five complexes
have now been reported to cause
different
genetic diseases different genetic
disorders which are shown here
and I'm
not going to get into most of these
genetic disorders and we
collectively refer to them as
kotopathies because they are diseases of
protein codes
and the defects in subunits of these
complexes lead to miss sorting
mislocalization of different cargos and
and that leads to uh to different
diseases
in today's talk I am going
to talk about kotopathies caused by
mutations in subunits of the ap4 complex
which are known as hereditary
paraplegia
uh or HSP
or also abbreviated SVG these are
synonyms essentially types 47 50 51 and
which are caused by mutations in each of
the four subunits of the ap4 complex
now let me tell you a little bit about
the ap4 complex I refer to this complex
about as the poor cousin of the ap4
complex family because
for many years there was very little
interest in this complex
uh it was it has four subunits named
named Epsilon beta 4 mu4 and sigma 4.
it was discovered in 1999 in my lab and
also the lab of Scotty Robinson at the
University of Cambridge in the UK and as
you can see in that gel those are the
four subunits of the complex that's how
we first discovered it biochemically we
knew that there was this complex or we
didn't know what it did
uh so a number of biochemical and
cellular analysis then showed first of
all that this complexes
evolutionarily ancient it's present not
only in humans but also in other
eukaryotes including a lot of protozoa
for instance
it's also ubiquitous it's found in every
cell in our body
now uh this complex however is present
at very low levels
and this made the study of the
localization and function of this
complex uh quite difficult and that's
one of the reasons why for many years
there was little interest in this
complex simply because it was very
difficult to study
um it's part of a non-classroom code
unlike the ap2 complex which
localizes to the plasma membrane
It's associated with the Trans Golgi
Network which is
the sub compartment of the Golgi complex
as you can see on the immunofluorescence
microscopy below
the arrows are pointing to the trans
Golgi Network and so that's where ap4 is
located so it's probably
playing a role in that organelle in that
compartment
it's recruited to the membrane by small
gdpses of the earth family
and the MU force of unit which is
depicted in blue in the skin binds
sorting signals in the Tails of
cytosolic sorry in the cytosolic tale of
transmembrane proteins feeding a
particular consensus motif
and the most important thing to note
here is that those signals have a
critical
tyrosine or why residue that's what the
new force of unit of ap4 recognizes in
detail of transmembrane proteins
and we even know the structure of the MU
force of unit of it before uh bound to a
sorting signal uh depicted in blue and
yellow respectively mu4 is in blue and
the Sorting signal is in yellow
and so all of these studies
revealed a lot of properties of the ap4
complex we knew where it was in the cell
how it was recruited to membranes what
kind of certain signals it recognized
and how it recognizes in Exquisite
detail even Atomic level resolution
detail
however
despite of all of these studies we did
not know what the physiological role of
ap4 was for a long time for almost 15 or
20 years
um
and it breaks through occurred
when several groups
demonstrated that mutations in each of
the force of units of ap4
cause a human disease known as
hereditary paraplegia or HSP
type 47 caused by mutations in the beta
force of unit
50 caused by mutations in the mere force
of unit
51 causal mutations in epsilon and 52
caused by mutations in Sigma 4.
uh
irrespective of which subunit is mutated
the patients have the same disease
because mutation in one savionet results
in
an inability to assemble the ap4 complex
and in similar cellular defects
so what is this disease hereditary
paraplegia well it's
characterized by stiffness and weakness
of the legs
so it's essentially similar to what's
known as cerebral palsy the patients
have the patients are children and they
have difficulty walking
and this is caused by
actionopathy of corticospinal tracts in
essence the axons of neurons that are
located
in the cerebral cortex and that run all
the way to the spinal cord are abnormal
they degenerate and that caused the
problems with
um with walking
uh now uh defects in ap4 mutations in
ap4 cause a form of hereditary
paraplegia as you can see in the
pictures on the left the children need
assistance for walking they need walkers
and but in addition these patients with
mutations in ap4 have other problems
including intellectual disability
seizures
microcephaly and it evolves to
tetraplegia in which they have problems
not only with their legs but also with
their hands so ap4 deficiency is a
complicated type of hereditary
paraplegia in which in addition to the
movement disorder there are a number of
other neurological problems
and neuroimaging Analysis of these
patients show that they have a thin
corpus callosum the corpus callosum is
the structure in the brain that connects
connects both brain hemispheres and in
the case of these patients is very thin
meaning that there are fewer connections
between the the two hemispheres and
there is also evidence of axonal
dystrophy of damage to the axons in in
these patients
and here you will see a little video
which is available in YouTube
of the two first patients in the U.S who
were diagnosed with this disease
and in particular these are two girls
Molly and Robbie who have mutations in
the beta 4 subunit of ap4 and this is
the day that they met for the first time
these two patients
at Boston Children's Hospital
and you can see that the they have
problems walking
and one of them is using a walker that
particular day this is their parents
and they were about three years old at
this time
and as you can see they have problems
walking but they still have use of their
hands
they can play together
and let me see was this all yeah okay
um and let me advance
and uh so those were the first two
patients diagnosed in the U.S but more
than 200 cases uh have been reported in
the literature throughout the world
and the belief is that this is probably
although it's a rare disease it's
probably more common than currently
known because it may be under diagnosed
a cerebral palsy
which up until recently was thought to
um because by trauma during birth but
nowadays it's believed to have also a
genetic component and in fact some
patients who had been initially
diagnosed with cerebral palsy have
recently been found to have mutations in
ap4 so it may be more common than it's
currently known
uh one
problem with these patients is that the
disease is Progressive
it gets worse with age you saw that
those girls were still able to interact
with each other and with their parents
they were still social
uh and they could speak a few words but
they will lose all of their abilities
eventually
they will become
tetraplegic they will lose use of their
hands and they will be confined to a
wheelchair because the disease is
Progressive it has a neurodevelopmental
component the children are born
with some problems but it has also a
neural degenerative components so it
gets worse with age
uh so that's a problem essentially that
parents see their children wither away
over time
but the progressive nature of the
disease also
offers an opportunity for early
intervention if we had
some therapeutic intervention we could
use it early and hopefully that would
slow progression
uh the problem is that there is
currently no treatment other than
symptomatic uh treatment and the problem
is that so these findings demonstrated
that ap4 is certainly important for the
development and function of the central
nervous system
so when we started this work we didn't
know what it before did or what it was
important for
uh these genetic studies demonstrated
that it's important for the function of
the central nervous system
so the problem is that we don't know
what a before does at the cellular level
how ap4 deficiency causes hereditary
paraplegia and this is something
on which we concentrated our efforts for
the past few years
and when up one approach that we took
let me silence this
was to develop a knockout Mouse
with a defect in one of the subunits of
ap4 to use it as a model system for the
human disease
and initially we were disappointing this
is the ap4
knockout Mouse we looked at it and
looked at it and it didn't seem to have
any problems
uh the mice were viable
they had no overt abnormalities they had
a normal lifespan and they were even
fertile
uh you could breed
if male and female mice with who were
homozygous for ap4 knockout and you
could you could obtain a progeny
so we were initially concerned that
maybe The ap4 Knockout mouse was not
recapitulating the problems with the
human disease
however we took our mice to a colleague
of ours Claire Le Pichon in our
Institute who is a neurobiologist a
neuroscientist and when she picked up
the mice by the tail she immediately
realized that there was a neurological
phenotype known as clasping
so when you pick a normal Mouse a wild
type Mouse by the tail
the mouse will splay their hind limbs
probably in preparation for landing on a
surface
uh so that's a spinal cord reflex uh
that that any mice will show
however when Claire picked up the
knockout Mouse she observed that the
mice kept their hind limbs retracted
so they were unable to recognize the
danger of falling on a Surface without
explaining their their hind limbs so
this clasping phenotype is very common
in it's a very common phenotype in
neurological disorders in the mouth and
for the first time told us the demise
did have a neurological phenotype we
only had to do we only had to challenge
them in order to see those those
phenotypes so we then perform other
challenges other neurological tests in
these Minds one of them is called a
rotor Rod test in which you place a
mouse on a rotating cylinder which
rotates at increasing speeds and then
you measure the speed the RPMs at which
the mice fall from the rotating rod
and as you can see here The Knockout
mice fell at lower speeds than the wall
type mice indicating that they did have
a motor disorder
we also performed a so-called grip
strength test in which we place
the mouse on a grid and then we pull
from the tail and we measure the force
at which they release
the grip on the on the grid and as you
can see in the bar graph
the mutant mice also had reduced grip
strength showing that even their
their their limbs have a reduced
strength
and we also looked performed
immunohistochemistry of the brain and we
saw uh in the lower picture that The
Knockout mice had a thinner corpus
callosum relative to the wild type mice
in the upper picture
also similar to the human patients
and finally we perform
immunohistochemical staining of various
parts of the central nervous system in
this case it's the cerebellum and you
will notice a in in those pictures shown
with the arrowheads that The Knockout
mice had swellings in the axons
called spheroids that were absent in the
wild type cerebellum
indicating that these mice also had
axonal abnormalities axonal dystrophy
so in summary the local mice had motor
deficits
a thin corpus callosum an axonal
dystrophy similar to the human patients
indicating that these mice are a good
animal model for the human disease
meaning that if we were able to develop
some therapies they could be first
tested in the mouse before they are used
in the humans
okay but
we still have not answered the question
what is the cellular function of ap4
what does ap4 do in the cells so that
its deficiency cause a neurological
defect
and we thought that the key
to answering this question was the
cargos
because what do adapter protein
complexes do they sort cargos they grab
cargos by the tail
they packed the cargos into transport
vesicles so that they can be delivered
to the right compartments so ap4 must
have some specific cargo that is Miss
sorted when we mutated before in mice or
when it's mutated in the patients so we
decided that if we were going to
understand a before function we needed
to identify the cargos
and in order to do that we perform
what's known as an affinity purification
of proteins that bind to ap4
and identification of those proteins by
mass spectrometry and it will not get
into the details of those analysis
suffice it to say that we identified a
number of ap4 interacting proteins
this included the force of units of it
before which are are highlighted at the
top of this list Epsilon veriform mi4
Sigma 4. the force of units co-purified
as expected
and then we identified a number of ap4
interacting proteins and I would like to
highlight here a protein known as atg9a
which means autophagy related protein 9A
it's a component of this cellular
autophagy Machinery the Machinery the
Machinery by which
cells eat themselves and I will talk a
little bit more about that later in the
talk
okay so ap4 recognizes atg9
etg9 is a transmembrane protein and
therefore a putative cargo for ap4 it
has two cytosolic tails and in terminal
uh tail and a c-terminal tail which are
indicated by nh2 and coohh so those are
sequences that are facing
the cytosol of the cells
and in particular we noticed that the
n-terminal tail the nh2 tail
had a sequence y q r l e which is
highlighted in red
that fits the consensus motif
for signals that bind to the MU force of
unit of ap4
so therefore this was indeed a putative
ap4 cargo protein
to demonstrate that we used what's known
as a yeast to hybrid system which is
used to
demonstrate protein interactions protein
protein interactions so
uh and I will not in get into the
details for how this works but in this
assay when the yeast grows
as colonies it means that there is an
interaction between the two
proteins that are being tested
and in this particular Tale the test we
saw that atg9a interacted with a mu4
subunit of ap4 as indicated by the
colonies
on the left side of the red box there
you can see that there is growth did
that means that mu4 interacts with the
tail of atg9a this is confirmation
of the Affinity purification and mass
spectrometry analysis
and we also saw that when we mutated the
tyrosine the wide residue in the y q r l
e sequence
uh that mutation abrogated the
interactions as you can see next
uh to the Colony uh in which there is
growth when we mutate the tyrosine to an
alanine residue there is no more growth
meaning that there is no more
interaction so this demonstrated that
the MU force of unit of ap4 recognizes
the cytosolic tale of atg9a via that
tyrosine containing sequence as expected
demonstrated that indeed there is
specific interaction of atg9a with ap4
but what is the physiological importance
of that interaction
in order to address this question
we looked at the distribution of
atg 9A in one type and knockout cells
in this particular case the cells are
Mouse embryonic fibroblasts or meth
uh stained for endogenous atg9a here you
can see two cells and in green you can
see the distribution of atg9a you will
notice that it's found throughout the
cytoplasm although it's more
concentrated in the center of the cell
in the region where
the Golgi complex and the transology
network are located
this is in Wild type cells
and then we looked in Mouse embryonic
fibroglass with a knockout in the
Epsilon subunit of ap4 and this is what
we saw
the results were really striking I
remember when the postdoctoral fellow
called me to the microscope to show me
the results and these results really
knocked my socks off because it was so
striking in The Knockout cells that
don't have it before
atg9a is concentrated
in the Golgi complex and the transology
network and depleted from the periphery
of the cell so for the first time we
could see what it before
was important for in cells it was
important to export
atg9a from the transcology network to
the periphery of the cell
this is in Mouse embryonic fibrolasts
from the mouse that we had previously
developed
what happens in humans
so we then looked in skin fibroblasts
from a normal human individual and it's
the same as in the mouse embryonic
fibroblasts
and then we looked in skin fibroblasts
from a patient with a mutation in the
mu4
subunit of 8 before and this is what we
saw just like in the mouse fibroblasts
atg9a was concentrated
was accumulated in the transology
network and depleted from the cell
periphery also in the human patients
okay so we didn't know what ap4 did we
now know that ap4 mediates export of
atg9a from the transology network or PGN
towards the periphery of the cell as
shown in this red box
and it shows atg9a going to A Pas which
stands for free autophagic structure
atg9a is an autophagy protein and it
functions in autophagy and this is what
I would like to tell you a little bit
about because we think that this is
related to the pathogenesis of the
disease
okay autophagy what is this pathway
autophagy means self-eating
cells eating themselves
so when do cells eat themselves well
under conditions of starvation for
instance
cells will eat some of their cytoplasmic
components mitochondria endoplasmic
reticulum other organelles in order to
generate
nutrients that they need to survive
until nutrients become available again
in the medium
but it's also a mechanism to dispose
of foreign or damaged particles
including bacteria and viruses
protein aggregates that form in certain
diseases including many
neurodegenerative disorders such as
Huntington's disease Alzheimer's disease
Parkinson's disease
and so the way it works is that these
cytoplasmic particles are engulfed into
a pre-order phagosoma structure
that then closes into an autophagosome
that you will see in the middle of this
pathway that fuses with the lysosome a
decorative organelle to form an auto
lysosome where the lysosomal enzymes
degrade
ribosomes mitochondria bacteria viruses
protein aggregates and all of those
particles
now HTC 9A
plays a role in this process
so the small vesicles containing atg9a
derived from the tgn by virtue of ap4
then move to these pre-order phagosomal
structures
delivering lipids so that the pre-order
phagosomal membrane can expand
and eventually close into an
autophagosome
and the atg9a functional is required for
another autophagy protein
named lc3 to convert
from an lc31 form to an lc32 form
indicated in red in this diagram
and we can monitor the Integrity of the
autophagy pathway by measuring the
levels of lc31 and lc32 by
immunoblotting as in as shown in this
immunoblot and you can see in the red
box that there are two bands the upper
band is lc31 and the lower band is lc32
an analysis of one type and ap4
Knockouts cells shows that there is a
decrease in the ratio of lc32 to lc31
which indicates that there is a defect
in autophagy
in The ap4 Knockout cells why because
atg9a is stuck at the transvology
network and it not it cannot get to the
forming autofhogs
now in neurons
autophagy is essential for this forcing
of protein aggregates
in certain neurodegenerative disorders
but also under normal conditions
that otherwise will cause external
dysfunction and degeneration
so in our neurons
autophagy is constantly getting rid of
abnormal organelles damage organelles
and protein aggregates that form and
that disposal is essential for the
maintenance axonal health
uh if you have mutations in certain
proteins and you have an overwhelming
amount of Aggregates forming in the axon
then that will overwhelm the autophagus
machinery and you will have accumulation
of protein aggregates which will lead to
axonal degeneration and death
for example in Huntington's disease
so to test whether the ap4 knockout
neurons had a defect
in the disposal of protein aggregates by
autophagy we expressed a pathogenic
Huntington disease protein abbreviated
HTT
which forms Aggregates indicating
indicated by the red arrowheads in the
axon of the neurons that you can
visualize better on the left so these
are very long elaborate axons and so you
can see a small number of Aggregates
indicated in Green in the wild type
cells but when we looked in The ap4
Knockout cells we saw an increase in
both the number and the intensity of
these contenting aggregates
indicating that the absence of it before
results in an autophagy defect in an
inability to dispose of these abnormal
protein aggregates in the axon of these
neurons and we think that this is what
causes the neurology neuronal
pathogenesis the axonal pathology in
both mice and patients with mutations in
AP form
so in conclusion
we discovered this complex ap4
many years ago for many years we knew a
lot of the properties of this complex
but we didn't know what role it played
in
um organismal physiology
[Music]
we now know that mutations in ap4 cause
adcs known as hereditary
paraplegia
and that The ap4 Knockout mice
recapitulate a lot of the
symptoms seen in the patients in
including thin corpus callosum
axonal dysfunction
and motor deficits and therefore the
mice are a good model for the human
disease and they are being used in
pre-clinical studies of disease and we
now know that ap4 mediates signal
dependent export of atg9 from the tgn
and we know that ap4 knockout sales
exhibit autophagy defect particularly in
neurons and therefore
autophagy dysfunction May contribute to
the pathogenesis of this particular type
of radiator is passing paraplegia
uh so in the last couple of minutes I
would like to tell you that these
findings have translational implications
uh in the first place this cellular
phenotype of accumulation of of atg9a at
the transology network is now being used
for diagnosis of this disease for
instance there may be some patients that
have mutations of unknown
um pathologic significance so we can now
test in fiberglass for these patients
for the accumulation of atg9a and the
tgn and that is diagnostic for disease
this phenotype is also being used in
drag screens for uh formal pharmacologic
agents that would be able to remobilize
atg9a from the transvology network
towards the cell periphery as a form of
alleviating the autophagy defect and
hopefully the defects in the patients
and and also these phenotype is being
used to monitor gene therapy vectors for
use in patients for the ability of the
vectors to remobilize atg9 from the
transology network and in this regard we
are collaborating we are part of a
Consortium led by Stephen gray and shin
Chen and the department of pediatrics at
UT Southwestern Medical School this is a
project that was funded by a charity now
a secure SPG 50 that's led by Terry who
has a son with ap4 deficiency
and as part of this Consortium we tested
uh some of these gene therapy vectors
that we found were very effective at
remobilizing atg9a in the upper right
picture where you can see atg9a
accumulated in the tgn of fibroblasts
from these patients and if you look in
the lower right picture you will see
that the re-expression of the missing
subunit results in dispersal of atg9a
from the transology network to the
periphery so Michael on the picture on
the left was the first patient to
receive this gene therapy four months
ago at the hospital for sick children in
Toronto upon approval of the clinical
trial but the Canadian regulatory agency
and now the patient the the therapy has
been approved by the FDA for clinical
trials in the U.S which will start very
soon
so this has been a long and very
fascinating journey to us from the
discovery of this complex in 1999 to the
elucidation of the function of this
complex
to the use of this knowledge now to
develop therapies for these patients
and I want to acknowledge the people in
my lab over the years who did these
studies they are the real stars of this
work I also want to thank our
collaborators in the US and other
countries
and also I want to thank my Institute
nichd which funded This research for all
of these years and finally I want to
thank all of you for your attention
thank you very much
yes and thank you Dr bonifacino for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
you will read the questions to me
because I don't know if I can see the
questions absolutely
um and we already have a few questions
um our first question Dr bonifacino ap4
is expressed in all cells why do the
patients have only a neurological
phenotype
yeah that's a good question uh so this
is a question that I am asked often when
I talk about
uh these uh neurological
disorders of protein trafficking
so I said before that ap4 is ubiquitous
it's present in every cell in our body
so why do the mutations result in a
neurological phenotype and I think the
reason is that neurons
are much more dependent on protein
transport than other cells
if a fibroblast
or a keratinocyte
or a lymphocyte have a defect in a
protein trafficking molecule they will
still manage they will hovel along they
will still
carry out their functions to some extent
and that may not be manifested as a
severe defect in patients
but if a neuron has a defect in protein
trafficking that's more likely to result
in problems and that is because the
neurons have these very long processes
like the axons and the dendrites some of
these processes may be up to a meter
long
for instance the neurons that
innervate your toe so that you can move
your your toe they have axons that are
up to a meter long
the the body of the neuron is in the
spinal cord but the tip of the axon
that's moving the muscle is one meter
away so if you have a problem with
moving proteins in the neurons they will
be manifested much more severely in
neurons than in other cell types and so
that's that's a common finding in a lot
of diseases involving components of the
protein trafficking machinery
so I hope that answered the question
absolutely thank you so much we have one
more question coming in do all
co-activities have a neurological
presentation
yeah that's related to the first
question so
I uh
that's this is a a term that we coined
uh recently because mutations in
um AP1 ap2 ap3 before ap5 and and many
other code protons that I didn't mention
in my talk
um they cause uh genetic disorders that
we refer to as photopathies all of these
protein codes are components of the
protein
trafficking machinery and for the same
reason that ap4 mutations cause
neurological disorders mutations in all
the other AP complexes and other code
proteins also cause neurological
disorders the there are many of these
disorders now dozens of these disorders
and most of them
manifest
neurological symptoms and the reason
being that protein trafficking is really
essential more essential in neurons than
it is in other in other cells
thank you so much one more question
bonifacino what are the next steps that
you will be taking in your lab to study
yeah so
um the ap4 deficiency is only one
of several
neurodevelopmental disorders that we
study in our lab
so and and
our interest is
elucidating the mechanisms of these
disorders in the hopes that we can come
up with Therapies
because if we don't know
how mutations in these genes cause
disease what the mechanisms of disease
are it's unlikely that we will be able
to come up with new therapies for these
disorders
and so a major focus of our lab is to
understand
the mechanisms of disease so that we can
come up with therapies with
pharmacological interventions or gene
therapy interventions so that we can
treat these children
it is estimated that about one to two
newborns in the U.S will develop
intellectual disability
and that's only one of various
neurological disorders so although each
of these diseases is rare when you
combine all of the movement disorders
and the intellectual disability
disorders they affect a significant
proportion of the population so my lab
as well as many other labs are
working to try to come up with new
therapies for these disorders through
the understanding
of the molecular mechanisms that unders
underlie the diseases
thank you so much in such an incredibly
important Mission Dr bonifacino thank
you for your time today would you like
to provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we go
well yeah I'm not sure exactly who my
audience is but I just want to mention
something uh
thank again my Institute
nichd which is one of the about 28
institutes that make up the NIH for
funding This research
nichd was established 60 years ago this
year is the 60th anniversary of our
Institute
and it was established during the
Kennedy administration
through the advocacy efforts of the
president's own sister Eunice Kennedy
Shriver who are lobbied
um the uh the government to establish an
Institute whose mission would be to
combat mental retardation as he was
known at the time intellectual
disability as we referred to these days
and so that was the initial mission of
nichd and it Remains the central Mission
these days
and within a few years within the first
decade of nshd's existence
a major cause of acquired intellectual
disability
was
was addressed through the development of
the vaccine to hemophilus influenza
also known as meningo Focus
which before that vaccine
caused
intellectual disability
in children in many children in the U.S
around and around the world and after
that vaccine started to be used in
children and anybody who has children
will know that this is a vaccine that
children receive within the first year
of age and that was eradicated as a
cause of intellectual disability in the
U.S and in many other countries
throughout the world so that really
shows how investment in basic and
translational research leads to
actionable treatments for children and
we hope that we can replicate that
success
for other types of intellectual
disability and other diseases in
children
well Dr bonifacino thank you again for
your time today and for this very
important research and before we go I
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted on demand
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand for two years
until September 21st 2024. lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care be safe
everyone bye-bye thank you